joining us now for instant reaction is
Senator Lindsey Graham member of the
House uh excuse me Senate I always think
of you as house impeachment manager or
worse thanks for joining us first time
in the Ingraham angle great to see you
thank you so you heard a little tidbit
there I'm what's your reaction very
important statement that South
korea-japan in the United States thought
the summit went well and we're together
behind president Trump now if my
Democratic friends would get by in
President trouble we may actually get a
peace deal some of them have write some
more progressive members of Congress
have actually come out it's kind of
shocking some of them actually before
the impeachment of Trump I think thought
you know let's give peace a chance and
yet there's a lot of the real criticism
comes from someone like a Chuck Schumer
or some of the more never Trump
Republicans sometimes they throw you in
that mix but I say that's not true that
you were the president have a great
relationship big fan of President Trump
see inherited a problem has been
building for thirty years there's no
place for him to kick the can
twenty years ago they didn't have any
nuclear weapons now they got a bunch and
they got a missile that could hit
America if they've married the two up
then we're in trouble and President
Trump has told me from day one the first
time I met him I'm not gonna let North
Korea have a missile that can hit
America with a nuclear weapon that's a
non-starter I'm going to offer them a
deal that they can't refuse her
shouldn't refuse that does South Korea
Japan in the United States are talking
as one really will help the president
yeah I have a brother who's lived in
Korea for many many years and he's still
there and he said like gathered around
little villages like he goes travels all
over he said the people were riveted
like every shopkeeper had a television
on and and he said let me tell you to
the South Korean people this is like
Gorbachev and Reagan this is the biggest
news the most positive development for
their lives because they still have
family in North Korea they want to have
a different scenario not just for peace
and safety but for their culture let me
use proud people very proud out there
over two million Emir of Quiana mericans
and they all have families president
trumping out talked a lot about this he
knows what a war would look like and he
would only do this if he had to cost a
lot of people are going to get hurt or
die and it's unnecessary but the
president has made a decision he's not
going to contain a nuclear-armed North
Korea because they'll sell what they
build he's going to bring the program to
end in a win way but Democrats who have
written a letter to him what a good deal
should look like I asked you one thing
tell the world North Korea and China
that if diplomacy fails because they
play the same old games all options are
on the table and get behind President
Trump when it comes to the military Rand
Paul says you're a danger to the world
because you said that I think military
options carry options always on the
table and well we actually get something
pissed not we're never going to get a
deal I don't want to use it the best way
to make sure we have peace is to
convince North Korea there'll be a war
they can't win Trump has done something
no other presidents done he's doing
everything he knows how to avoid a war
and I would beg North Korea and China to
take him up on it
it just came out before you came on that
the Pentagon is expected to cancel yeah
the August military exercises with South
Korea are you concerned about that is
that too soon to cancel so the president
called me on Air Force One he says
listen I'm trying to let him know I'm
serious these they happen twice a year
they're designed to tell North Korea if
you get in a fight with South Korea in
the United States you lose I'm willing
to stand down to give them the space
they need to make an intelligent
decision we can always put the exercises
back on schedule but this may be the
last best chance in our lifetime for
peace and this is a bold move by the
president we're not going withdrew our
forces but we're given North Korea a
sign of goodwill and some breathing
space and I don't blame him for doing
this to those who criticize the
president how well did you do with North
Korea but you criticize them for
complaining about how much it cost to do
these in it I watched you on another
network last night Lindsey I'm watching
if you're watching I do how much money
it costs but I kind of like the fact
that the president's always worried
about the taxpayers money whether it's
money we give overseas to countries that
trash us or but not to say that's not
important I think most people are like
good he's a good job of the federal
government to defend the nation the
number-one job for for those in the
Congress and the president's give the
military the training and equipment they
need so when you're training together
your allies this money well spent
we're trained so we don't have to
like it's it's incredibly important to
our readiness and news and this in the
in the military will tell you that good
night good luck president we ever gonna
pull our troops out of there he said
that to Bret Baier that's what he
ultimately wants that money at home
twice because if we pulled out China
would run through the you know they're
doing the South China Sea I'll be a sign
of weakness to China and China's
double-dealing now they're beginning to
back off if you play Trump you met with
him you shook his hand you told him you
wanted to give up your nukes for a good
deal if you play this guy you're gonna
regret it
this is not Barack Obama don't play
Trump look at poor Justin Trudeau so do
that the candidate